the national socialist was it was a very
largely technological regime you know
nuclear war is the creation of
technology you know the gene modifying
technology biowarfare these are all
things that are
either there or almost there with the
capacity to to wreak un
imaginable suffering on the entire
planet because of the technology that's
not to say that technology is bad it is
to say rather that it
must take its place relative to a higher
order series of conversations and what i
absolutely want to insist on is that
those higher order conversations they're
not mere intuitions they're not mere you
know you know speculative oh we can just
kind of you know consult the the the
entrails of a goose or something they're
also not mirror expressions of the
arbitrary desire for power because
that's exactly central animating spirit
that isn't why you built raws that isn't
why you're trying to build ralston
college it isn't to fulfill your own
desire for power that's not a good
motivation it's not pleasing it doesn't
last it's not enriching it's what people
turn to when they're bitter and cynical
[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased to have with
me today dr stephen blackwood who's the
founding president of ralston college a
newly founded university in savannah
georgia dr blackwood was one of the
founders
of saint george's youth net an
educational mentoring program for inner
city youth in the north end district of
halifax nova scotia and was subsequently
a teaching fellow in the foundation year
program at the university of king's
college which is one of canada's finest
undergraduate institutions blackwood
hosted and moderated a conversation
between sir roger scrutin and i
at cambridge university in november of
2018 and moderated the debate happiness
capitalism versus marxism between slavo
zizek
and i on april 19 2019
dr blackwood lectures and specializes in
the history of philosophy especially
boethius
he also hosts the ralston college
podcast
which has featured guests including
douglas murray the physicist freeman
dyson andrew doyle the online satirist
and author and theodore dell rempel who
wrote our culture what's left of it
among many other books
oxford university press published his
book the consolation of bethes
as boethius as poetic liturgy in 2015.
welcome dr blackwood stephen it's really
good to see you thanks for agreeing to
talk to me today
thanks for having me and jordan it's
great to see you again i think the last
time we yeah i think the last time we
actually saw each other i believe was
during the debate with slavojijek
is that correct that is right i think
that is right yeah so it's two years ago
so maybe i could ask you first of all
about the
inner city youth program in north end of
halifax i don't know that story so that
might be a nice place to start
well i
i grew up in eastern canada and then a
place that you would know but perhaps
not all of your listeners know in prince
edward island and a sort of
pastoral quiet sleepy very rural place
and a small family farm
in a huge well comparatively by historic
standards a huge fan by contemporary
standards rather huge family
seven younger brothers and two younger
sisters
my parents uh the milk cow
i don't want to paint too idyllic a
picture everyone knows family life and
farm life has all kinds of
kinds of
ups and downs
but the point i'm
trying to make is that i
i had a very kind of intensely
wonderful and rich and very actively
busy
childhood and
and it set me up in many respects for
the discovery of of philosophy when i
went to college and i had the the
immeasurable gift of
meeting some teachers who
just open worlds to me i mean you know
what a teacher can do and be
having had them yourself and having been
one for so many people um
and i i really fell in love with uh with
trying to
think deeply about you know fundamental
matters and
not that i was pretty good at it by any
means but just that
it was
eye-opening for me to see that things i
had perhaps intuited in my childhood
about the nature of things in some deep
sense we all have these intuitions
whether through nature or music or
love or or or
family life or whatever that there were
ways of thinking about those those
things and i spent quite a long time
with some wonderful teachers
particularly in the
ancient greek and latin and then um
medieval tradition
thinking about things and particularly
about the nature of the human individual
what it is really
what it's
it's realization
is
um
anyway i mentioned all that because when
i came to the end of my master's degree
i'd gone straight through you know doing
a lot of you know thinking work
in a wonderful community it needs to be
said
i just uh
i had kind of in a way had my fill of of
ideas and i i
i had kind of tapped out i had gone as
far as i could in the theoretical at
that point and i
i needed to re-engage in the not i
wouldn't say the real world but in the
more you know the more the the the world
of of of
of uh activity and action
and i had a dear friend and mentor of
mine named gary thorne who
was the the priest at an inner city
parish called saint george's
church in halifax nova scotia
and he had been with others including uh
one of my sisters had been working in
the inner city thinking about uh
uh
which was i should say a very rough and
uh dis highly dysfunctional place
at north end of halifax is that is or or
was and in some respects still is but
not least because of a
absolutely catastrophic uh civic
decision there was a place in halifax
called africville
uh black community uh that though
perhaps was not
uh entirely up to contemporary standards
in terms of technology and things was a
vibrant place that duke ellington had
played there it was a flourishing
community
anyway the city wanted to build a new
bridge
and part of the foundations of the
bridge they wanted to put in africville
so at least that's the story i've
understood um from my own reading about
it and they they they uprooted this
entire very vibrant community
uh out of the place that had been called
africville and resettled them in
pretty dismal inner city housing in the
north end and
that was not by any means i think the
only factor but a very significant
moment in the devastation
of a community
and
when i was there in the late 90s
uh into early 2000s mid 90s to early
2000s
there were very many you know pretty
uh
pretty
serious
problems from uh drug and alcohol abuse
to
a prostitution
devastatedly broken families
and my friend gary thorne and others had
been thinking about what modest you know
one doesn't think one can solve these
really very serious problems
you know simply walk out and solve them
they're they're really hard um but what
could the parish that i say this
community do that might be meaningful
and
so i was with a group of people involved
in setting up a a small very small this
is a small community but small uh youth
mentoring and life skills program called
st george's youth net and the idea was
to be a kind of network that would
pick these
help pick these children up when they
fell and to give them
well
our observation father thorne's
observation had been over many years
that
that if you wait until someone has
already fallen through the cracks uh
it's in many respects and this is a
terrible thing to say i know but in many
respects too late it it's very hard to
reach people not that it's impossible i
believe in redemption i believe in the
whole possibility of things being turned
around uh right down to the
most you know
tiniest fibers of my being
but the point is is that it is very very
hard to do that with someone who's 16 or
17 or 18 already fallen out of uh you
know dropped out of school
you know had a baby whatever um
so we
thought about ways of
we thought about what we could do to
to expand the horizons of these children
and youth of all ages you know really
but uh starting with them as young as as
school age and working with them and i
won't go on at length about this but
what i
learned was a couple of things that are
still really really with me today
the first is that
human
the realization of the individual has to
come down at a very fundamental level to
the individual like no one else can live
your life for you you know no one else
can kind of come in and just do it for
you that that would that would that
would that would deny all of the agency
that is at the heart of human you know
fulfillment and and and and and the
driving force of this is me this
meanness of life has to come from me
um
and in a way i think that's a standpoint
that
that at some loose level you know people
would call the political right seems to
understand that you know there has to be
agencies fundamental
and yet that is a totally incomplete
standpoint at the same time uh because
uh you know we don't simply throw
children out into the woods and say you
know all right come back when you're
fully formed you know you know writing
books and playing the playing the flute
and and and and fully able to take on
the complexities of life
one of the
things that's so striking to me is that
it
as people have ability one of the things
they will
throw all of themselves into
is the raising of their children and so
damn well they should uh my wife and i
have not been blessed with children
unfortunately but i i as the eldest of a
big family and having observed and my
friends and many others you know they
will just
give everything they can
to
carefully
tend to this to the development of each
individual they're not all the same even
in a single family you can only have two
children or three and they can be very
different as day and night and yet they
will give everything they can to these
and so well they should but what this
points to i think is a really
fundamental question which is you know
what are the conditions the external
conditions for human realization and
what we found
with these
beautiful
often
you know children in very very very
broken circumstances
is that on the one hand we had to have
high expectations for them and their
agency we had to insist that they'd be
there on time that they that they that
they treat others with respect that they
be attentive and to anything less was to
betray
their own dignity and potential what
they could become and yet on the other
hand we found that we had to move heaven
and earth to make those opportunities
possible for them we would go around in
the in the mornings and pick them up at
their home because they didn't have
people who would get them there on time
and we would
make various other kinds of let's say
accommodations to make things accessible
for them and and and and and lastly i
will simply say that you know
it's not enough just to keep people busy
you have to give them ways that open up
their own understanding of themselves
and so we we took them wilderness
camping many of these were kids who'd
never been outside of inner city halifax
we took them to to to cape ship necto a
beautiful uh park uh on the bay of fundy
and was in three days you know hiking
through unbelievably beautiful uh uh
terrain and and and we we
we had music programs and and uh our art
uh
fine art programs and and later on they
they were teaching them latin after i i
left and the point is is that
i don't
overestimate what good we did for anyone
but insofar as we did any good for them
i think it was in
in
it was in believing that helping them
believe that they mattered
that they mattered at the highest plane
of existence
that
they were that they belonged to that
highest plane of existence it wasn't
just enough to you know learn technical
skills or as important as those are or
to note that you needed to come on time
to have a chance in life
but that
you were made the highest and best
things there are were made for you
so anyway i've gone on rather long but
that's a it was an important part of
life and i came to see things that are
still
grounded
it's an interesting conclusion to draw
from that kind of work because
the latter part of that in particular
was spoken
like
a true believer in the humanities
and i suppose we can transition our
conversation to that i mean the first
thing i'd like to ask you though before
we do that is you grew up in this rural
community you went off to college what
sparked your interest in philosophy were
your parents educated i mean how did you
come by the interests that you have
well i think it would be
[Music]
so interesting when you think about
childhood and what really is formative
you know you don't make a kid a
philosopher by reading him aristotle at
six um
my upbringing in my parents and my
siblings were
unbelievably important to my sense of
the world to my sense of what a human
individual is
to my sense of what's
good
my sense of the possibilities of
redemption and so on and so forth
so i would say in a very deep way
my earlier childhood
um
opened me up
to be able
to then later think about things in a
more abstract or philosophical register
but you know philosophy doesn't exist in
a vacuum i mean it's not for no reason
that you know plato and aristotle
are are after homer
and the the
the
things that you can only really think
about things that you already in some
sense into it
uh you you don't just sort of abstractly
go off and you know discover
um
uh
things that
the deepest thinking is about
you have to already have them in some
form
um
you know you you have a sense of
well you could take anything you can
take um
the
difficulty of life or the
the beauty of a sonnet or or the beauty
of nature or the the
the the
the horribleness of suffering
and
it's very hard to think about these
things in the abstract if you've never
suffered and never seen suffering of
course most human beings at some point
do in pretty serious ways
uh but the point is is that um
one of the things i think we absolutely
need to think about very seriously as a
society
uh and as parents and as educators and
so on and so forth are what are the deep
forms the deep things that
form
that shape an individual in such a way
as to open up that horizon later in life
and you know i know you've done a lot of
work on early childhood development and
reflected at length on things like play
in piaget and others
um
you know
everything in its own time in a way that
is right for the stage of development um
but
what i'm
saying is that i had
some very
deeply formative
encounters with things that i think are
of a very and i think these are not
exclusive to me they're they're they're
universal human realities but i had the
privilege of encountering some of them
in my youth in a way that then when i
went to
college i went to this place called
king's college
founded in 1789 by loyalists who went
north from
new york at the time of the american
revolution
from an earlier
university in new york called king's
college which at the time of the
revolution was renamed or after just
after then renamed colombia but the
loyalists went to a more northern
colony at that time of course this is
all pre-canada and they set up king's
college
and kings had been failing in after it
relocated to halifax in the early 70s
and teachers of mine founded a place
called the or a program called the
foundation year program and
my son took that as well oh that's right
yeah so tell us about that
well it is really just a
a crash course introduction to
principally
western the history of western culture
not exclusively western but going back
to
to uh in fact to very very back from
mesopotamia up through the ancient
greeks the medievals the renaissance
ah the age of enlightenment and the
contemporary world and you you'd simply
read and think and hear lectures about
and discuss uh books uh uh and that
wasn't the kind of introduction to those
things and then i realized that the
teachers who set up that program were in
the classics department at dalhousie
university
some magnificent
teachers and i spent then spent the next
three years doing a bachelor's in
classics and then and masters there but
that classics department i should add
was particularly strong in the the
philosophical let's say the
the big ideas that were moving in that
period uh
not that learning languages and things
didn't matter but they were particularly
strong in those
careful readings of
texts that really can change your life
if you attend to them
so i
uh
in my early days of
my undergraduate degree i
encountered people who were reading
these texts and
saying things about them that enabled me
to understand the things that i had
perhaps intuited when i was younger
in a more self-conscious rationally
universal frame which is of course
philosophy is so i've been thinking well
you've been talking about something that
i've been writing about and i've been
working about on this for a long time so
i'm a
behavioral psychologist and so
behavioral psychologists are eminently
practical we tend to break things down
to the smallest
applicable unit of action right so if
you're trying to help someone move
somewhere better
well you want to figure out what better
is but then you want to decompose that
into
actions that are likely to be undertaken
and those might be very very small
actions and i've been thinking about
the question of the meaning of life and
the first
objection i suppose i wrote that arose
in my mind was an objection to the
question itself because there might not
be a meaning in life there are places
where people derive meaning and
and
you can list them and it's useful
practically if people are thinking about
how to organize their life if they're
unhappy and they want to know how things
might be better i mean my observation
and obviously not only mine is that
people generally need to have a career
or a job to keep the wolf from the door
but also to engage them productively
with others which is a primary source of
meaning for conscientious people and for
creative people alike you need to be a
you need to pursue your education
to to flesh out your intellectual
capacity you have to take care of your
health physical and mental you
you need an intimate relationship you
need a family you need friends you need
intelligent use of your leisure time you
have to regulate your
your uh susceptibility to the
temptations that might lead you astray
drugs and alcohol and perhaps
pornography and those sorts of things
and but then there is a a core to all of
that
around which these more practical
endeavors arrange themselves and that's
something like attention to the
spiritual or the philosophical
domain or the religious domain i think
you can in some sense put all those
together and and that might be well
it might be that the attempt to answer
explicitly or at least to address the
question of well what is all of that
practical life in service of and you
said for example that when you were
working with the inner city kids
in halifax you were trying to help them
realize that
the they were meant for the higher
things and vice versa and someone might
ask well what's the
why bother with that when you can just
bother with the skills and it seems to
me that the answer is something like
well we all have to make decisions about
how we're going to behave in life and
how we're going to act ethically and if
you help people understand their
relationship to what's ultimately noble
then you can help them
fortify their
their
resolution to do good in the world
instead of to do harm it's it's it's
it's it seems to me to be
i mean i think we're always deciding
with every decision that we make whether
we're going to do good or do harm by
action or by inaction and
whether we should do good or harm or
nothing at all i think depends to some
degree on who we think we are and and
what we're capable of and it seems to me
that the humanities when when they're
properly taught are
the study of who we could be each of us
as individuals and we need to know that
because otherwise we'll be much less
than we are and that's not a that's not
a trivial problem it's a cataclysmic
problem
and and i also think that people pine
away in the absence of that i mean you
sent some questions
that we could cover and one of them was
well you you said topics that might be
relevant include our historic cultural
spiritual civilizational crisis what is
it its root for example their idea that
there is no truth but only power
and the vast longing
hunger of our moment you said i think
the woke phenomenon is at least in many
cases an index of that hunger although
it miserably fails to satisfy this
intrinsically human desire for
transcendent purpose
and so
in to me the universities are the a key
element in the conversation across the
generations about just exactly what a
human being is and and that's something
that it's not some abstract
philosophical it's not merely some
abstract philosophical concern it's
it's the central issue that
determines how you make all the
decisions in your life
so
i just i just think that's completely
right i'll say two
things just quickly that the first is
that uh you know my my father's a
medical doctor and he
worked in the er for
many many years and has seen many people
die
and
he's remarked to me that no one on their
death bed you know looks back and says
gosh i wish i'd spent you know more time
at the office or i wish i'd you know
uh you know accumulated
more riches uh uh
for myself
um and so i i really do think you're
right to say that
that there is nothing more important
than
how we understand
ourselves
i mean um your human life can't be lived
for some other end i mean you can you
can do all kinds of things you know for
certain ends you mean you might work
hard to get a qualification uh in order
to get a job in order to uh make money
in order to provide a home for your
family but at a certain point it stops
and it stops it's not for something else
it's for the lives of these people that
i am living that i my life and for the
lives of the people that i am seeking to
live in relation to there's not those
are then not for something else
and
so the the the point is that
our self-understanding i mean you can
you can regardless even you can even
look at this i think jordan from a from
an evolutionary standpoint i mean
human beings are evolved as creatures
that are self-conscious they are
self-understanding they have self-uh
self-regard and this is you you may
think that all of the ways in which they
regard themselves or the things in
relation to which they understand
themselves whether it's truth or beauty
or or purpose you may say all those
things are just you know you know
constructs of the will to power which of
course is what you know that the
dominant nihilism would have us believe
but but but
and which i do not accept which i think
we can show to be wrong very clearly
rationally philosophically however
even if you
think they are constructs
you still
do not escape the fact that
human beings are evolved in this way
such that their how they understand
themselves
is absolutely fundamental to their
nature like that is what we are as an as
as an evolved species
and so
any culture
that
does not enable
human beings to
understand themselves in a way that they
find to be richly meaningful and i'm not
saying meaning is just a construct but
if it does not do that at the end of the
day it has failed
its fundamental test yes
yeah okay so now let's look after this
power idea
and be okay so you
you seem to
agree with something that i've also
concluded that
what's at the root of our current
cultural malaise is this
idea
that
human social institutions and then also
by implication primary individual
motivation
that human institutions are predicated
on power
and so
the more i've thought about that the
more wrong it seems to me to be and i've
also been thinking about
truth and lies some more and you know
there are those lies that you tell when
you just skirt the truth a bit
so
there may be the ones that are most easy
to get away with and often most
effective but not always but often most
effective because maybe they work the
best
you take a truth and you bend it a
little bit and
that's still a lie but then there are
ant there are statements that are
antithetical to the truth
their their anti-truth lies and i think
that the idea that human social
institutions especially the functional
social institutions of the west that
they're predicated on
the drive to power i think that's an
anti-truth
i don't and so so let's see if we can
take that apart a little bit i mean the
first question might be
well
what exactly is the
definition of power who's making these
claims and what's the definition of the
power of power and why are they making
the claims
so let's start with who's making the
claim that that
our social institutions are predicated
on power
well it does seem to me to be a claim
that comes pretty fundamentally out of
the academy i mean
one of my
constant refrains is that the academy
the university that is upstream of
absolutely everything else you know
culture policy politics art and
architecture family life you know media
just go down on through the list
and i think that these
narratives or frameworks are proceeding
fundamentally out of certain
uh forms of
20 but really 19th and 20th century
philosophical critiques many of which
were important and even necessary and
illuminating in their their um
in their original form
but which have been made into
very reductive
totalizing forms of seeing the world
and so is it reasonable do you think to
in i've talked about post-modern
neo-marxism and of course people who are
critical of the way i think point out
that well post-modernism hypothetically
is predicated on the
idea that all grand narratives are to be
questioned which you would assume would
include the grand marxist narrative
which
presumes that
the most appropriate way to view human
history and human social institutions is
by positing the existence of an
oppressor class
economically in a subordinate class
economically the bourgeoisie and the
proletariat and so that's the
fundamental analytic lens through which
marxists approach the world
that
those who have have because they've
taken from those who have not and that
the implication there is the fundamental
animating principle of our social
structures is exploitation for the
benefit of the few and then of course
this is my view anyways when marxism
became untenable ethically as an
explicit philosophy in the late 1960s as
a consequence of the revelation of the
absolute catastrophe that the maoists
and the stalinists had made of the
of china and the soviet union
respectively
there that post-modernism transformed
marxism into something that was more
palatable on the surface but that
proclaimed that well it wasn't exactly
economics that was
exploitation that was at the root of
things it was just exploitation in
general it was
the manifestation of the power
drive let's say that keeps people who
are
in positions of power above the rest and
who have at their disposal the means of
compelling those people to do
what they would not do otherwise against
their will that's an expression of power
as well i mean do you think
do you think there's something like am i
wrong in that formulation i mean i've
tried to understand this i'm not trying
to be
what would you say
um
biased or blinkered about it it's just
that's the way it looked it looks like
that to me i mean people like daredevil
and foucault
they were marxists to begin with and and
so
and isn't it the case that the notion
that our social relations are structured
as a consequence of the expression of
arbitrary power
isn't that merely a transformation of
that initial marxist presumption or am i
am i barking up the wrong tree here
well i would say a few things versus
that i'm very far from a scholar of
these you know complicated intellectual
movements from the late 18th through to
the century through to the the present
um but in my reading certainly in the
main
there's uh uh
there's
uh
in the main
i think you are right about marx and
again i'm not a
philosopher of marx but if you read for
example the uh the the introduction
uh to his critique of hegel's philosophy
of right you know
he outlines very very clearly this this
dynamic of focusing all of the force of
one part of society against another as
an essential kind of material dialectic
and that does seem to me to be
fundamentally what is you know that is
the that is the logic of the power alone
revolution i think that is fundamentally
what we're facing in the uh well that
leads to a war of all against all of
course but it certainly leads to to
identity politics warfare and the
reductions of of an individual to
wherever they can be usefully mobilized
in a battle
of one part of a against another um but
i would also say about about
marx and again
just to think of the new as you know
when you get into
studying complicated things you always
feel you must endlessly qualify what you
don't know um there's a huge amount i
don't know about marx but i also know
that he says that um
uh religion does not make man man makes
religion and at some very fundamental
level there appears to be
whether in marx or proceeding out of his
interpreters a wholesale negation or
rejection of the idea that there is any
abiding metaphysical or transcendent
reality well he and marx also points out
very clearly that
and this is a key element of marx's
thought that
social structures structure individuals
individual consciousness and it's not
that individual consciousness structures
social structures so it's the group
imposing its
nature on the individual rather than the
group being led by the individual and
that's a profoundly anti-enlightenment
and i would say anti-judeo-christian
proposition and so and that's certainly
something and then you said something
else that was interesting you know you
said you're not a scholar of these
movements and neither am i and that's
actually a problem right because we're
trying to address this
appearance of a culture war that seems
to be manifesting itself first in the
universities and then everywhere else
and it's an amorphous thing it's hard to
get a grip on and it's easy to be wrong
but we're forced to contend with it
regardless and to
sketch out its outlines and i've been
trying to do that as fairly as i
possibly can i mean
part of this proposition seems to be the
the
the insistence the radical insistence
that
the enlightenment uh
insistence on the individual as the
primary unit of analysis is to be
discarded in favor of a group centered
analysis and that the only reason that
that individual the idea of the
transcendent individual manifest itself
was because it served the interests of
those who have
arbitrary power to maintain it although
the logical connection there isn't clear
because it isn't obvious to me how it
served the particular power interests of
that group and how it wouldn't serve the
power interests of other groups equally
as well seems to be a fundamental flaw
in the logic
but
in
i've been thinking about my own
experience with
social institutions and and
and my knowledge of how people develop
as well as how children develop and the
first thing
or part of that is that
all the developmental literature
suggests that
the use of aggression which is what
you'd expect
to be developed if power was the
fundamental
organizing principle of social
institutions you'd expect that
aggressive
children would do better than
non-aggressive children
and you'd expect that children would be
socialized by their
uh
their their super ordinance their adults
their teachers their parents to manifest
aggression in the service of power and
that doesn't seem to be the case
developmentally the children who
preferentially use aggression
self-centered aggression in particular
tend to be alienated and unhappy and in
in a dismal minority and friendless and
then they don't do well in life at all
and the developmental course is from
more aggression at the very early stages
of life to less aggression as adulthood
inculcates itself and so we actually
become more civilized as we become more
integrated in our social institutions
rather than less
and so
why do you think the
and then
i think about my relationships with
no i think about two things people i
have admired who've been successful in
social institutions and then my
experience as a apprentice let's say
within social institutions and
first of all the people i admire and
who've been successful are not by any
stretch of the imagination
um notable for their
manipulation of arbitrary power
quite the contrary the the people that
i've met who are particularly admirable
have done everything they possibly can
in their positions of authority and
competence to open the door
to advancement to people around them to
facilitate their cooperation to work
with them genuinely in a
in a manner that
increases the probability that both of
them will succeed and they've also taken
extreme pleasure in
the development of
their subordinates
so to speak and then i thought well
doesn't
how is it that our culture has got so
bloody warped that we don't notice that
you know you talked about the importance
of family
in your upbringing and you speak of your
family with great um with great
affection i mean
why don't we believe that the central
patriarchal spirit is
properly constituted as benevolent
father rather than as tyrannical power
mad
you know exploiter
because i don't see that
people who are tyrannical power mad
exploiters actually do that well in our
social institutions
and it also seems to me that it's a
primary pleasure
to open the door to people
who
have ability but less opportunity like
it's really it's a fundamental
motivational pleasure for that to occur
and i think it's integrally related with
the pleasure that people take in
fatherhood
yeah and i think well i think that's
completely right and it needs to i think
it needs to be said well a couple of
things the first is that
the this rich view of the individual as
having as really mattering as as being
uh connected intrinsically to
the the to reality itself you know facal
faster gear is one phrase that the
french give us you know face to face
with god but you see this in the ancient
greeks you see this uh all throughout
the the the uh well you see this
developing in all sorts of ways
throughout the institutions and
philosophical artistic movements of uh
western culture i'm not saying not in
other cultures it's just that this is
where i this is the tradition i know and
and did some
level of
scholar of but the the the the point i
want to make twofold first that these
ideas of the of the individual way
predate the enlightenment uh and in many
respects the enlightenment itself
is though responsible for many of our
clarifications around these things has
also left us with many problems um uh
that that we're i think going to have to
face
or we're finished really fundamentally
and
but the second thing i want to say is
that
it's not that thinking about power is
not important i mean
there is there are very few things in
the entire record of human beings
thinking about what it means to be a
human being which is essentially what
the humanities are right i mean it's
just the record of other people thinking
about human experience throughout time
whether it's art or philosophy or or
theology or logic or architecture i mean
these are these are the record of the
ways in which people have grappled with
what the human being is that's all the
humanities are fundamentally but at the
heart of that and
there are few things more that occupy
more
bandwidth in that whole long arc of
reflection than
how one
restrains
the
individuals
own solipsism it's the individual's own
will to power the individual's own you
know closed loop of the self against
everything else uh which which it turns
out in this rich tradition of reflection
is an extremely bad thing for the
individual to do because it's alienating
because the individual that
it's short-sighted and it actually runs
con see this is the problem with
positing that the drive to power is the
central animating
principle and to make a fundamental
critique that might be expressed in such
terms as systemic racism let's say
i mean that the drive to power
and deceit perhaps in in the service of
power is best viewed as an aberration to
the central tendency a powerful
aberration and certainly the source of
all the fundamental corruption of the
central tendency but it's not to be
confused with the central tendency
itself which is more like
properly construed and i think that this
is perhaps the central message of the
old testament properly construed as
something like a benevolent father
i mean the greeks had their metaphysical
reality too i i i spoke with an author
this week and a professor of classics at
boston university the author is brian
moresky wrote a book called the
immortality key and he was talking about
the
eleusinian mysteries and the greek the
saturation of greek culture in this
in this underlying metaphysical
religious reality that was manifested in
the ellusinian mysteries and
and and in the dionysian tradition as
well we talked a little bit about the
transformation of the dionysian
into the christian
as a consequence of the union of greek
society and jewish society out of that
comes christianity and this new
conception of man as
as
akin to divinity in some sense
or a recreation of that idea
i'm fumbling for words here but i'm
trying to get a picture of the central
animating spirit because what we're
pushing out of the universities is the
idea that we're fundamentally motivated
by group centered tyranny and i don't
believe that to be the case i i don't
think that that's what good people are
motivated by and i don't think that bad
people are particularly successful in
our social institutions i think that's
an unbelievable i think that's an
unbelievably cynically cynical and
dangerous way of looking at history and
it's also a way of looking at history
that demolishes your own motivation
because if the central animating
tendency of our social institutions is
the expression of tyrannical power then
that's the defining characteristic of
your own ambition
but if your own ambition is to develop
yourself as a noble being who has a
broad purview and who finds fundamental
pleasure in serving the higher good well
that's a whole different story it's and
the story is the critical thing here and
that's what the universities are
supposed to be transmitting is that
central story
and if we're wrong about this we're
going to tear things down
yeah yeah well i think i don't think we
need to say we're going to i think in
many respects we have already
very you are going to critique the
enlightenment
well i think we have already very deeply
deconstructed many of the forms of life
and culture that
actually mediate the individual's
agency and deeper realization and we
were saying a minute ago that that that
you know if you look at things simply
from the standpoint of power and you
analyze individuals by that i mean with
the the paradox is that you know if you
tend only to your own power you know you
you are a disaster you're a disaster as
a human being you're a disaster in
relation to others uh you you you you
end up
wildly unhappy and unfulfilled i mean
that is just that is the price that's
right
the path downward
on in every level it's not like you can
be an individually successful psychopath
exploiting everyone and end up
hedonically
advantaged without suffering that isn't
how it works i've never seen that happen
it it
i don't believe it's possible and so i
can't understand why we've bought the
idea that power is the central
is the central animating principle like
what the hell
and why have it
there's an envy in it there's an envy in
it that i can't quite put my finger on
it's it's related in some sense to this
you know i've noticed that in the
universities whenever i worked with
business people for example
a lot of my peers would become upset
with me
and i always wondered why that was
because my sense was well there was just
as many good people and bad people in
business let's say as there were good
people and bad people in academia it was
just completely
foolish to draw an arbitrary line but it
had something to do with envy
and
i was talking to paul rossi you know
that the new york teacher who got nailed
for first standing up against the
importation of critical race theory
let's say into the private schools in in
new york and he talked about the
attraction that post-modern theory had
for him when he was an undergraduate he
he wanted to be a writer but he didn't
really have the talent as far as he was
concerned and along came the post-modern
critics who were tearing literature
apart and they appealed to his
resentment and his envy because they
were tearing apart you know an ideal he
couldn't reach and so it was very much
reminiscent to me for me of the story of
cain you know who
who became resentful and bitter because
his sacrifices weren't accepted by god
it's the fundamental story of human
beings really
and so there's this envy that's driving
us to to misinterpret our institutions
and to be careless with them and the
universities seem to be leading the pack
i would say more than leading yeah
certainly yes certainly leading uh ra
racing onwards um i think that
you know one of the terrible ironies of
this this standpoint is that
it becomes guilty of the very things
that it uh it it uh it accuses in others
and so
it it it it violates our institutional
life it violates our whole relation to
the past it violates the individual that
is to say when you drink the kool-aid of
there being only power all the way down
you are in a grim world
and
what is i think so
tragically perverse about the dismissal
of our whole inherited past with all of
its complexity and beauty and difficulty
is that
the tradition itself of all of
humanistic learning
has many of the very tools we need to
confront the problems that the those
concerned with those those who are
concerned with the abuse of power
are concerned about and so
the the and i think revolutions often
work work in this way is that the first
thing they need to do is alienate the
entire record of the past from the
present because that's the basis upon
which you bring in the brave new world
you know through your own manipulation
of of power and system and so on and so
forth so i don't i mean i think
there are a number of things going on
it's always
very tempting i mean the siren song of
power is is is is there's a kind of uh
uh
drug-like character to uh
to that but i think jordan we need to
ask you know
why is it that these
um
reductive
inadequate manifestly a historical
irrational
utterly you know low-grade uh uh kinds
of analysis have become so dominant and
i think if we can't answer that question
it is difficult to
transcend their hold
on
those who
ascribe to them well you said that
um
the woke phenomena is an index of the
vast longing slash hunger of our moment
i mean the the other thing one of the
other things that rossi said that was
quite interesting was that
when the
the new
doctrines entered the private school
that he was teaching he was initially
highly supportive of them because they
came in flying let's say the anti-racist
flag
and like who isn't
happy about anti-racism and so if you
take it at face value well then
you get to put yourself on the side of
the heroes that are fighting against
those who oppress people on the basis of
arbitrary characteristics like their
race
and so that certainly accounts for
some of the attraction on the positive
side i mean the negative side is well
the the opportunity to tear things down
for the sake of tearing them down in the
name of some higher moral virtue that
just covers the real motivation which is
to tear things down because you're
envious but you know to give the devil
is due
well there's something to be said for
working
identifying with a movement that
purports to be serving the interests of
the poor and the dispossessed and and
those who are
prejudiced against and
and to take to task those who are
perpetrators of such things and so i see
that as part of a religious impulse to
do the good but it's so incomplete and
it's so um
it's so dangerous in its incompleteness
because well partly because it provides
a say a too convenient enemy and partly
because it does dispense with the
richness of the past and
well and then it brings with it and it's
in its
in its wake let's say all sorts of ideas
that are entirely counterproductive um i
mean
it contains within it a fundamental
critique of the idea of free market
economies for example which to me is
just a disaster
just from a computational perspective we
can't do
with central planning what the market
can do with computation because it's
distributed and it relies on the choices
of everyone it's a much more effective
computational system but we seem to have
done a pretty bad job of defending it
well i think it's it
that's a very very good statement of the
problem
why is that so i mean
it's
it
well let's say a few things the first is
that
i do think the whole woke thing which
you know for whatever
i mean it's
for whatever uh
whether that
what that even what that word even means
is i think is it is a is a good
question to dig into fairly carefully
but um
i think
it is an index of a search for meaning
in it in a deep sense at least for many
of course there are many people who just
cynically take things up they know it's
a power move it's a power political move
they know what they're doing full well
it's it's it's wrong it's reductive it
destroys people's lives we know that's
what's at work there are always people
who will do this but in in a much larger
sense i don't think that's an adequate
analysis i think that at a larger level
it is an index for a search for meaning
um and we i think need to
to remember aristotle's uh fundamental
insight into the human psyche which is
that you know one is only ever moved by
some kind of a perceived good you you
that's why for dante you know you go
down to the bottom of of hell which is
just an allegory for him about this life
not a vision of the afterlife you know
things are frozen there's no
movement at all because the good of
intellect or even any perceived good
however limitedly or obscurely perceived
is gone it's just frozen and so whenever
there's any action at all it's because
there's some kind of a perceived good at
work even if that is completely
misperceived i'm saying it's a perceived
good we never do anything at all you
don't go up to make yourself a sandwich
or go get the mail or say hello to
anyone without some kind of a perceived
good
and and
this so the second thing i would say is
that
i think we need to think
of
times when there is a signifi therefore
we need to think about times when there
is a significant amount of momentum
behind something it could be national
socialism in the in the 20s and 30s in
in germany it could be the the movement
to uh scottish independence in our own
day it could be the the so-called woke
movement black lives matter whatever
whatever whatever lens we want to look
at this from we need to really honestly
ask ourselves the question what is
moving in this and i think it's clearly
the case that uh from the the the from
what i uh understand about the the
formation of uh the the complicated
historical movements that led to the
second world war that um
there was in germany at least i would be
very surprised to learn this is not the
case a a vulnerability
to
an
a
an ideological standpoint that gave a
defining collective purpose
and
that seems to me to indicate a lack of
that not being done in a better way uh
you could say the same thing i suspect
about scottish independence is it really
that scottish independence or is it that
well you know if you were in canada in
quebec
and you were a lapsed catholic a french
catholic you were four times as likely
to be a separatist during the separatist
you know uprising say in the 1980s and
1990s in canada or 1960s through the
1990s
uh the gallup gallup poll
indicated that and and
so
you know quebec was the last place in
western europe in some sense that so to
speak where catholicism
dissolved and that didn't happen until
the late 1950s and it was instantly
replaced by a radical nationalism which
really i mean i watched it from the
outside i was in quebec for much of that
it was impenetrable you could see that
it was a displaced religious doctrine
the state had taken the place of christ
that's the simplest way of putting it
well
that's a great i think that's a great
that's that's a great historical example
i mean i think that at a minimum what
many people perceive in these these
these sort of so-called woke movements
is at least some
incipient or in kuwait vision of justice
that you know the least of these among
us matters the different among us
matters now of course i think that the
standpoint that is uh through which
these things are viewed as completely
tragic and unfulfillable of the unable
to fulfill the very ends that it seems
to bring about but what but you know the
the conservatives and you know free
market lovers and all these people very
often lament the fact they say why is it
that you know this
we call it the left call whatever you
want seems to beat us on the moral
argument every time despite the fact
that we know that that that our systems
and the ideas that we espouse
historically have been shown to be
superior to the very values that the
so-called left is beating us at and
i think that this does raise the fact
that
it
you know
i've been reading the
tupes wonderful coffee table book i know
you had a wonderful conversation with
him recently about you know how much
better everything is is is getting in
and terms yeah in absolute terms and you
know these are these are this is a
wonderful it's a very important book
these are wonderful achievements uh we
should all rejoice and and absolutely
you know face face them and be glad for
them and the things that they will make
possible but it is also very interesting
to note um
what is not in tupi i mean there uh
there is uh uh
there's no talk about beauty there's no
talk about architecture there's no talk
about cultural achievement there's no
talk about let's put it this way there
is no talk about many of the things that
are most fundamental to the meaning in
human life and that's not to degrade or
denigrate the achievements that are
being spoken about there but it is
rather to say that that that
if your metric for
human flourishing is do we have enough
to eat and are we not getting rained on
and you know you go through these lists
of kind of fundamentally material things
all of which are fundamentally important
and not only because they're material
because there's also a spiritual
dimension to those things for human
beings but the point i'm making is that
you see the same thing in stephen
pinker's work like the blank slate
i'm sorry i hope i've got this right
because i've read a couple of pinker's
books but one of the things so he thinks
very much like two p thinks and he wrote
the better
angels of our nature if i remember
correctly as well
showing that human aggression has
decreased substantially over the last
number of centuries but
the all of the uh qualities of humanity
that you
describe
are sort of
they're parsed off near the end of the
book into a single chapter as if they're
just secondary side effects of some more
profound rationality let's say and it's
the rationality that's concentrating on
material
well-being and i'm i don't have anything
against material well-being and and the
elimination of privation but there is
and it's interesting that you make that
comment about tupi's work is that that
the spiritual dimension it's like the
list of of of of
of what should be attended to to have a
meaningful life that i listed at the
beginning of our talk
at the end i capped that off with some
attention to be paid for the spiritual
or moral or religious element of life to
bring everything together it's and that
narrow focus on
material well-being
necessary though it is does seem to lack
to
it there's something in it that's
missing that's absolutely fundamental
that if it's missing undermines the
whole project or appears to
well i think the bottom line is that
there
there is no
deep human realization for any
individual outside of understanding her
or himself in relation to higher order
principles truths realities i mean
that's just what human being that's what
human beings are so that is not
to denigrate the necessity of
improvement in all these areas that
toopy so brilliantly chronicles i don't
portray myself as somehow anti-tupi i'm
a huge fan of of this i'm a huge fan of
the inclusive institutions that they
describe as necessary to human human
flourishing but i think it needs to be
said that in the most developed places
so-called developed places of the world
skepticism about those inclusive
institutions is higher than anywhere
else or at least arguably so i think it
needs to be said that
there's there's there's nothing in the
book about the very disturbing uh trends
of rising suicide of of rising uh
although dopamine addiction of porn
addiction in in in in in young and young
men of course especially these are
and i think it needs to be said that
many of these
things that appear to be a very
fundamental miles of contemporary life
are also related to technology and one
of the paradoxes i think that i love to
ask you about jordan relative to your
own work on the individual and human
individual realization is that
if on the one hand human beings are
becoming increasingly liberated from you
know the demands of material necessity i
mean the amount of time it took to they
they bring up brilliantly to create
light for example was an immense amount
of work or created to save up enough
calories to make it through a winter all
of these just this this the bone
grindingly hard aspect of human
existence for for millennia then we are
very rapidly in the last two centuries
uh
now almost every human being in the
planet not everyone but the vast
majority are living at standards of
living that were inconceivable by anyone
just a few centuries ago so these are
these are these are these are amazing uh
uh
achievements but it also needs to be
said that insofar as on the one hand the
individual is being liberated from
these uh uh those bone crushing
realities
at the same time it does appear to be a
key aspect of modern life that
individuals are finding themselves less
connected more alienated and
that the very technology in some
respects that liberates them also
appears to homogenize in a kind of
globally reductive way such that you
know
as human life is lived on the ground the
frame in which it's actually lived and
where in which meaning is derived that
that has become more distant uh uh
harder to access and that we have far
fewer of the tools we might have once
had to make sense of that all-important
sphere
i've talked to bjorn lomberg and to matt
ridley and to marion toopey and to other
people who are deeply concerned about
continuing to make
absolute privation let's say a thing of
the past and
and to many people as well who are
hoping to ameliorate relative privation
which is more the concern of the left as
you already pointed out
and all of these people are also aware
and and stephen fry for that matter you
know stephen has allied himself to some
degree with the four horsemen of the
atheist world and is a dramatist and so
understands at least in his bones the
necessity of
this underlying poetic dramatic
religious humanistic matrix out of which
rationality has emerged and in which
rationality must remain embedded i mean
what it looks like to me is that
and and i see this dawning realization
among people like richard dawkins as
well at least by proxy um talking to
people who know him and watching what's
happened to him with the humanists for
example who attacked him is that
this
insistence on pure rationality and pure
enlightenment rationality
doesn't address the fundamental
religious impulse and the hope was among
the four horsemen of the atheist world
let's say that
once we dispensed with this irrational
superstition we'd all become
materialist rationalists you know of the
intellectual caliber of stephen pinker
but that isn't what's happening i don't
believe that that can be the case
what happens instead is that all sorts
of things that
religion should be separated from
the higher life the spiritual life the
religious life
all of that falls down a level or two
and and and pure politics becomes
contaminated with the religious impulse
and then it becomes totalizing
and that looks like a catastrophe and so
it seems to me that
we need to pull up the
spiritual domain again
to parse it off as a separate field of
of
what endeavor study hope
to give the to give it it's due and that
the that's the role at least in part
that the university should be playing
instead they're tearing things down
yeah and i think it needs to be said i
mean these these these
technology is an amazing tool that's
what it is it is a tool it does not have
a moral value in itself you know it's
it's it's and it's in it's it there's no
question that it largely well
it is it is morally in
uh uh uh
uh what is the word i'm looking for it
doesn't have a moral determination
intrinsic to itself uh uh but but
so that is to say even from the
standpoint of the this kind of narrow
instrumental rationalism you still are
putting this in service of something
that you think right right that you
think is good you know it's good to feed
people but you know you have to ask you
have to ask yourself you know why do we
think peace is better than war or why is
it that that
forgiveness is better than vengeance or
that um that unity is better than
disunity or that beauty is better than
ugliness and this is the point that i
know we ought we we both are very keen
about maybe we can talk about beauty in
a minute but the the the point i'm
making is that
uh is twofold so that's that's relevant
to that central animating spirit of of
mankind let's say because
that central animating spirit
accepts all those propositions that you
just laid out as givens that beauty is
preferable to ugliness that unity is
preferable to disunity that that um life
more abundant is preferable to privation
and that's all part of our our central
ethic and that's part of the central
ethic of our properly functioning
institutions as well
and it's part of the central ethic that
enables us to communicate about what's
good and what's evil and it's part of
the central ethic that allows our
consciences to torment us when we
deviate from that path and that's not
merely a matter of
aberration from a central power drive
yeah i mean i think there's a real
question you know the the
you know
the west the world at large could very
easily become a technological order set
over a moral vacuum and this is not to
denigrate the technology but actually it
will destroy itself right that's what
look what i mean it's very easy to point
that out i mean you know we can you know
the the the national socialist was it
was a very largely technological regime
you know nuclear war is the creation of
technology you know the gene modifying
technology biowarfare these are all
things that are
either there or almost there uh with the
capacity to to wreak
un
imaginable suffering on the entire
planet because of the technology that's
not to say that technology is bad it is
to say rather that it
must take its place relative to a higher
order series of conversations and what i
absolutely want to insist on is that
those higher order conversations they're
not mere intuitions they're not mere you
know you know speculative oh we can just
kind of you know consult the the the
entrails of a goose or something they're
also not mirror expressions of the
arbitrary desire for power because
that's exactly animating spirit that
isn't why you built raw's that isn't why
you're trying to build ralston college
it isn't to fulfill your own desire for
power that's not a good motivation it's
not pleasing it doesn't last it's not
enriching it's what people turn to when
they're bitter and cynical and and feel
that there's nothing left but the
exploitation of others for momentary
pleasure it can't you can't be more
cynical than that
and so we also have to ask yourselves
why the hell did we get so cynical about
ourselves
it doesn't i mean
gosh that is such a good thing do you
remember that you remember in that in
that debate with g-jek um
there was a a piece that we're going to
clip out and but it's part of something
i already clipped out of a 15-minute
piece of that debate
i talked about
the communist manifesto as a call to
bloody violent revolution
and a significant proportion of the
audience who were obviously pro-marxist
and had come to hear zizek hopefully
defend their hero
um cheered and laughed when i talked
about bloody violent revolution
and you know
it it's also the case that
once you make the
prop
look
i've i've been trying to understand for
example when the left goes too far
you know where's the cut-off line
it's very difficult to draw but the
problem with the
insistence that power structures
everything is that as soon as you
insist
upon that you justify you can't help but
justify your own use of power and then
that for me
as a psychoanalytic thinker let's say
then that makes me suspicious that
perhaps that's the motivation for the
entire
bloody argument it's like well
everything's about power so it's
perfectly fine for me to express power
in whatever way i see fit especially if
i'm serving the oppressed or i'm serving
some higher moral order
but really what i'm trying to do is to
find a justification for my
expression of naked power and you could
see the enjoyment in the crowd when that
phrase about bloody violent revolution
popped out it's like yes yes it's really
that's what you want and who is it
exactly here that's animated by the
desire for power
and so
i mean is the is the driving force
behind the insistence that all our
social institutions are based on power
the desire to justify power as a as a
political weapon
that is inevitably a significant part of
the attraction
though i think it takes its strength
fundamentally morally from the
the the perception
that this mode of analysis
can help us redress
um
well you wouldn't be suffering you and
so yeah you insisted earlier and i've i
was speaking with someone else who made
the same case
very recently i i can't remember who it
was but it'll come to me um
you know that there's no impulse to
action without a drive toward the good
but i'm not so sure about that i think
that people can become
hurt enough and bitter enough and
resentful enough um
so that they are driven by the desire to
make things worse that that that there
isn't a good opposite oh oh certainly
but that that's i mean i know absolutely
but i mean there is there's a there's a
however misperceived there's some end in
the activity i'm not saying it's it's
it's
just be like because i've thought about
hitler in this regard too it's like
there's this old psychoanalytic dictum
that jung i believe formulated i haven't
been able to find exactly where he he
stated it unfortunately but
the gist of it is that if you don't
understand the motivation for something
you look at the outcome
and you infer the motivation
and so then i look at hitler and he
committed suicide in a bunker
after berating germany for failing to
live up to his noble ideal left the
entire country in flames left the entire
continent in ruins
in this massive conflagration he was
always interested in the worship of fire
i mean and so you know one
interpretation would be that hitler was
attempting to
produce you know a new world order
another would be that he was aiming at
committing suicide in the midst of
europe in flames
and
that was the outcome and i'm kind of
look likely to attribute that motivation
you know you can think about it as a
warped attempt to to pursue the good
you know in the in the form of let's say
an extreme nationalism and and the
binding of a tribe but to me it's more
shaking his fist at god in the sky and
saying you know here's here's my revenge
on the world you created
and i don't see a good i don't see any
drive to good in that except
peripherally
oh sure
sure i'm not i'm not saying i'm
certainly not saying that these things
are actually good what i'm saying i know
i know you're not yeah yeah that the
action that the action
however uh uh perverse
perceives
even if it's just the the perception of
the furtherance of the self-stone will
to power you know there's what i'm
saying is it's moved by a perception of
an end and that end may be completely
cataclysmic uh i'm not i'm not not it
wouldn't frankly that's why the whole
work of education
the whole work of
of education of of parenting of of our
social institutions aims at
we hope
enlightening or helping the individual
to better perceive
what is
really good good and
and so you know let me ask you about
that so i've been thinking
psychologically again about
christianity
and i know that christianity is an
extension of other metaphysical
forms of thought
but
that predated
but it looked to me like and and some of
those were derived from mesopotamia and
some of them were derived from greece
and some of them were derived from
judaism and other sources
but they all seem to me to be
part of the conversation that human
beings have been having amongst
themselves
for thousands of years about what the
nature of the ideal human being is
and now i see these cathedrals these
works of art in architecture that took a
tremendous amount of labor
and produce a dome-like structure that
represents the sky and you see christ as
logos
spread out on the sky as a transcendent
force and you ask yourself well what
exactly is that
signifying and the answer is at least
the proposition of a kind of ideal
that's associated with let's say
universal love and truth in speech
that's the logos
summed up in two phrases and
if there's no metaphysical reality there
at all there's still this imaginative
enterprise that characterizes the entire
human
what imaginative effort
cultural effort to posit a transcendent
ideal that we would live in relationship
to
and i just don't see that case being
made very strongly and i can't really
understand why because isn't it rather
obvious that at least part of what
christianity has been is the attempt by
thousands of people over thousands of
years to specify the nature of an ideal
certainly i would say so and i would say
that the fact that
these uh principles
uh actually work is uh proof of their uh
of the
proof of there being true accounts of
what the nature of the real is um well
let's let's approach this from a couple
of different angles jordan you know the
first is
one of the things that i i profoundly
believe is that
you know these young people seeking you
know deeper answers and you know to
however
much they may be flailing about
you know it's not
their fault
that many perhaps most of the
institutions they will encounter
will betray that which is deepest in
them we'll we'll we'll we'll denigrate
we'll tell them no none of this thing
that none of these things that you're
seeking are really real i mean i think
you know i've been talking uh
uh thinking a lot over the years about
architecture and what is going on in
brutalist architecture and and it really
does seem to me that in brutalist
architecture to live in relation to
brutalis architecture it is as if you
had a parent that said you know you're
nothing
you're nothing you'll never amount to
and of course there are terrible people
terrible to say people actually there
are people in these situations who live
with with such dysfunctional uh uh uh
lack of love and antagonism this is the
way that this is the home life that they
that that some people uh terribly have
but i'm using this as an example because
i think what brutalist architecture does
is it declares to the whole world and to
you that you are there is no truth there
is no beauty you are nothing accept it
it's just a concrete
uh uh uh
annihilating force and and and and and
you see this culture of repudiation i
mean here in in in not here you're in
canada i'm in the states in savannah now
but you know the the chateau laurier i
think i misspoke recently called it the
the frontenac which is in quebec but in
ottawa you know the chateau laurier
there's been a
a desire to expand this sort of
beautiful sort of neo-gothic building um
and it went through six rounds of
approval to finally uh be uh to
make a set of plans that would meet the
local architectural
uh uh
or review board whatever it was and i
thought well it can't be that bad it's
gone through that and i mean this
structure is abhorrent it looks like a
cross between a a verizon server firm
and an american penitentiary i mean it
is just
it is a declaration that there that
there is no higher order you know in
edinburgh they're tearing all those out
hey there is edinburgh is an
unbelievable beautiful beautiful city
the the whole central
mile of it square mile essentially is a
unesco world heritage site and it's
marred by
random placements of 1970s brutalist
architecture
and that they're just horrible it's it's
complete lack of regard for the
architectural context and
they're all being torn out and replaced
thank god
so
well this architectural idea so back to
the cathedral you know what's really
interesting about
a cathedral with let's say christ as
pentecreator on the ceiling is spray
spread against the ceiling is that it's
not the state
that's portrayed up there right it's not
a it's not a map of the country it's not
even a map of the world it's not a
geographical locale or a political
institution it's the transcendent
individual
and you know
it's just not obvious to me it's a it
seems obvious to me that that's correct
that and that if it isn't the
transcendent individual then it becomes
the state and as soon as it the
transcendent becomes the state then we
have a catastrophe
and i don't see any difference between
the insistence that our identity is
predicated on our group membership i
don't see any real difference between
that and the insistence that we're just
handmaidens of the state it's a
totalitarian insistence and i think part
of that too is maybe you know i learned
from jung that as soon as you posit an
ideal you also specify a judge
and the more the higher the idea the
more severe the judgment
because of your distance from the ideal
and so part of what we're seeing too
might be a rebellion against the
awful
requirements of that ideal
but that doesn't justify that doesn't
justify the rebellion
because if it's really the ideal then if
you don't act it out it you you fail to
act it out at your peril
and then we need to have a serious
conversation about the metaphysical
about the
about the practical implications of the
idea of this ideal i mean if if we've
had this conversation about the
transcendent individual as the ideal
against which we should all be judged
and and to which we should struck that
we should strive to emulate
is there
is there any relationship between that
ideal and the structure of reality
itself because that's the that's the
100 question so to speak
you know we we have a human ideal and
you could say
merely psychologically maybe even merely
biologically that that's something we
originated that's that's part of our
biological nature that's expressed in
this ideal and it's nothing more than
that but you could also say well perhaps
it is something more than that perhaps
it's reflective of the structure of
being itself
i mean it depends on our
position in the cosmos you know we are
self-conscious we are that which
reflects being itself or perhaps even
makes it possible it's not that obvious
what our role is
it might not be so trivial
despite our mortality
well i would
say that not only it is as you say but
we can know it to be as you say i mean
this is what the
whole uh history uh in some sense of of
literature and philosophy and theology
is about is a is a and i want to insist
on this it is a rational
uh grappling with
these questions
realities and indeed truths um
uh i want to come back to something in a
minute but uh just on this topic
you know one way into this is to
reflect on the
the fact that that reality is not zero
sum
that of course we know this economically
you were talking jordan a minute ago
about you know free you know the the
voluntary exchange of of of uh regulated
that is to say a contractually governed
uh marketplace
um that that in this exchange
you know
it's not
zero sum we all end up over time better
um but you also see this naturally in
the the evolution
of the diversity of species of languages
of cultures you've written beautifully
about
play as orienting the child in relation
to a deepening reciprocity with others
we know this in terms of knowledge i
mean you know how can it be that in a
conversation i can be wrong
and be shown to be wrong and that be a
net gain for me i mean you know i
the whole
point of free dialogue is that we can
learn from we can learn in our not
knowing
that the conversation is not zero sum
that even in the in in our in our speech
we know this in terms of forgiveness
that even our betrayals of beautiful
things can become deepening
engagements with what we have betrayed
if we have the humility to see it
and
so then you know i think
you know that
leads one to
you'll want geez you can go back you can
go at the level of subatomic particles
in physics uh uh the pleasure of talking
with freeman dyson uh before he died
and you know dyson will say very clearly
that against the determinists you know
some of the rational optimists are
pretty religiously determinist in their
in their world view um you know
and they want to marshal modern science
as as as saying that their determinism
is what science teaches uh but that joe
dyson who was a subatomic physicist at
the highest level uh you know
expressly said the opposite he said that
the electron
that you know you the essentially he
says that the electron is free that
consciousness is not an epiphenomenon
that at the very most detailed
level of subatomic particles things are
not
determinist and the reason i want to go
all the way down to that level is
because you can go down to the lowest
level resolution then you can back up to
the to the higher level and see that
there is a non
zero sum nature to what is real and then
you have to ask yourself
is it good to live in relation to
to
what is true or should i live in a
delusion and we say well it's better to
live in relation to what's true than to
live in relation to a delusion and and
and then you say well what would it mean
then for me to
live in relation to this this positive
sum this essential reciprocity which i
think is really what the christian view
of the trinity is about this essential
reciprocity which is the bedrock of all
reality what would it mean to live in
relation to that what would it mean to
to to remember that
and
you know
one can approach that in any number of
different ways but certainly that is
what what prayer is that is what all
spiritual exercises are that's what
perhaps walking in nature can be that's
what what any kind of meditative uh
activity intellectual or physical is a
recollecting of the self
in the deepest way to what is most real
and i know you've written for example
about about gratitude and i love your
words about gratitude uh because it's an
inversion of the burden it's not that it
all comes down to us but actually just
the opposite that we
we place ourselves in the hands
of
the
eternal
reciprocity
that gathers us up and puts us back
together
and i think that this frankly is is a
deeply rational standpoint that can be
shown to be despite my not making it
very articulately here today shown to be
true in economics in physics in biology
in sociology and certainly in all of the
higher order uh spheres of human knowing
this is the nature of what of what
we are and and what
the world is and this is where you know
you're right your your image of the
pantocrator you know i think this comes
back to this because because what
fundamentally is going on there is that
you know the logos is in us
you know it's actually in us that's why
when you talk about the divine
significance of truth and speech
uh that you know we are made to
understand ourselves in relation to the
whole that is an intrinsic human need
and an intrinsic human ability and and i
think that you know this is where you
know you know my life is about trying to
in whatever small way i can you open if
the nihilists darken the horizon and
close off in the way the brutalist
architecture does close off what we're
allowed to become and understand
ourselves uh as then i think the work of
our time is to open it back up and and
and and that is really what the
humanities are fundamentally about you
can go back to you know one of the
things i despise about the current
structure of the academy is it acts as
though you know these things are just
for the few
but you know you think about you know
homer i mean homer was the mode of
educating the greeks for you know a
thousand years the pantheon was right
there on the highest hill where everyone
could see it same with gothic
architecture you know j.s bach perhaps
the greatest musician who ever lived was
a parish church musician anyone i
presume could walk in the doors and
listen to his to his to his to his
cantatas i mean dickens when dickens
wrote i i've heard recently people would
line the docs
to wait to see what was the next you
know what was the next installment of
dickens and so what what i think you
know most fundamentally is that the the
antidote to the spiritual crisis
civilizational cultural crisis we're
living in is is is is is
really fundamentally
simple in at least it's what we can
state it as and that is to to to open
the horizon again to turn the lights
back on and what that means is to turn
them on so that individuals can better
come to understand themselves in
relation to these higher order realities
in the image of which they are made and
in relation to which their fundamental
realization essentially depends
so we have
so
there's critiques of let's say
thought in relationship to the ideal the
freudian critique of religious structure
that
it's infantile
and and perhaps that's a consequence of
the hypothesis of the divine afterlife
that awaits us all
freud regarded that as an infantile
response to the reality of death and
then there's the marxist criticism that
religion only serves power and it's the
opiate of the masses
but there's
i i it's striking to me how poorly the
alternative position has been defended
given its unbelievable power i mean look
we all seem to recognize within
ourselves that we have moral culpability
as far as i can tell because i've never
met anyone who hasn't tortured
themselves to a tremendous degree as a
consequence of their own perceived
inadequacies in relationship to the
ideal
i see that people take the deepest
pleasure that's possible in life in the
facilitation of the development of
others i i don't believe that
i believe that's wisdom to notice that
to say well it isn't the
the service to my
momentary desires for pleasure or even
comfort for that matter where i'm going
to find the deepest
significance life-sustaining
significance that keeps me away from
nihilistic hell and and the desire to
destroy and hurt it's it's going to be
something like service to the greater
good and primarily in the form of
well other people in their longest
possible term interests and that we have
not only a divine responsibility to do
that but a divine capacity to do that
that if not manifested
uh cripples us spiritually and and
physically for that matter
and
i mean the ultimate significance of that
remains unknowable but i don't see any
logical flaws in that in that
in the proposition i mean i looked at
the manner in which the mesopotamians
built their savior marduk
marduk has eyes all the way around his
head and he speaks magic words the the
cosmos comes into being and disappears
as a consequence of his utterances and
like there's this
sense emerging in mesopotamia as the
consequence of the aggregation of all
these cultures that the highest order
being is extraordinarily attentive hence
the all encircling eyes and is capable
of the deepest and most profound speech
and that's not a realization that's in
any means trivial that the mesopotamians
had wars between all of their
representations of their gods and what
they elevated to the highest position
was this all-seeing
truth-speaking capacity that also went
forward and confronted chaos and built
the world as a consequence and the
influence of that set of ideas or the
derivation from the set same set of
ideas for the
jewish conception of yahweh is quite
clear and you see the same thing
emerging in greece with with the
building of a pantheon of gods and the
proposition that something occupies the
apex something apollonian or something
of that nature
and then
you see that revolution take place
with the dawn of christianity and the
insistence that
there's something fundamental about
consciousness and
spoken
and and what's and and the spoken truth
that is constitutive of reality and you
ask yourself well do you believe that
and the answer is well you treat people
like you believe that because you hold
them responsible for the consequences of
their utterances and you judge their
character on the basis of what they say
and you and on whether or not they act
out what they say and so we hold each
other to these standards with everything
that we do and we berate ourselves when
we don't live up to them and i don't
understand how it is that we can be said
not to believe it
now you know there's the dogmatic
element the hypothesis for example that
christ is literally the son of god and i
mean my knowledge runs out very very
rapidly when speculating about such
things but i'm certainly
it certainly seems to me that
christianity has at least been a very
long conversation about what the nature
of the good is and that that's spilled
out
into the humanities and and underlies
our culture and that
that
that that has very little to do with the
expression of power it's it's the it's
not the right lens through which to view
things it's devastating it's wrong it's
cynical
and i think it appeals to envy and and
the desire to tear down
well well i i i i think i think that
the
well two things i would say just very
quickly jordan the first is that you
know uh we have immense resources in the
uh in our own past and in the past of
every culture i mean one of the things i
love about your work is how syncretist
it is you know here you've moved
in the last five minutes you moved from
marduk to you know the pantocrator to uh
uh to the greeks and and good on you for
doing it i mean that's that's uh i think
uh i want to say that
uh
you say people have not been good at
making the counter argument uh well um
uh
you've been very very good at making the
counter argument and uh the millions of
people who've had their lives uh touched
and ennobled and deepened by
uh
by um
taking seriously the things you point
towards uh are proof of that um
i
you know i think relative to our
spiritual cultural uh crisis uh we
should not pretend that we don't have
resources i mean it's as if
it's as if
you know the situation is is if you were
to give young people uh uh
the challenge of
building something beautiful and if you
were to
if you were to say well you're
absolutely not allowed to look at or
have any knowledge of any previous
building well the results are not going
to be very good but as soon as you say
and you can go back to palladio and
vitruvius and look at all these models
and discover all of the things that they
give you i mean the results
will be amazing and so i what i want to
i want to drive towards a kind of uh
optimism not rooted in in kind of uh you
know silly blindness about the depth of
our problems but rather uh in in the
the the nature of what is most real and
the whole treasure house of of tools
it's like we have these spotlights from
the from the past to help us understand
ourselves and the the the
the the world around us in philosophy
and religion and literature in
architecture and our in in art and
painting and music i mean for god's
sakes i mean we've got we've got
an unspeakable
treasure house
here and and
the
it may be that as we dig into that we
see that we uncover ourselves more
and understand ourselves more uh
adequately you know i want to do one
example
for example i think one thing that is as
a uh
i live in the in beautiful city very
beautiful city in in historic savannah
and i'm live on the edge of a
just absolutely a stunning civic space
uh park called forsyth park i hope you
can come and see it someday there's a
beautiful fountain in the middle of it
and it has these these these oak trees
these live oaks that were planted by
people long dead now these oaks of you
know one to two to even 300 years uh old
and
i not infrequently see uh young couples
coming to stand in front of one of the
biggest the biggest oak inside the park
proper
to uh to get married you know they stand
there with the justice of the peace and
uh
exchange simple vows and i think we have
to ask ourselves
what in the hell is going on there
and it seems to me
you know very beautiful and in a way
very simple it's that they wish that
their vows
they are aspiring to be to each other in
some way as the oak tree as
able to
live up to
the
um
the love that they are
called to
and they want to instantiate that uh by
uh
by that's why you turn to the garden and
the tree in the center yes
yes and act out adam and eve
yeah reborn
yes yes but there's a related point i
would make and that is that
that you know
we're not we are not starting fatherless
in the regeneration i mean i i
absolutely you know i'm the president we
have to the father is nothing but a
tyrant
yes well that's the thing we can't do we
got to stop thinking that way
the father isn't a tyrant
yes yes
you know this is what's so
sad i mean you you know i've been in
enough cities with you to be have been
very touched at the people coming up to
you and i know you
all almost invariably get emotional when
you discuss what it means to you to have
people come and thank you for your work
um and
um
what i am so struck by in in those
experiences and in the people who
come increasingly to us at ralston
college is
i mean we had a young man drive all the
way from utah uh without telling us uh
in the hope of just um
meeting someone here
had someone moved to savannah a former
military
young man
with again without telling us and the
question is what is going on there um
you know these young people who turn to
us are not
they are not animated by the culture
wars fundamentally they are already
seeking out higher order realities uh
they want to
give themselves to rebuilding things in
a
beautiful and fundamental uh way
and
i think
we need to remember we see we must
absolutely not
by the line that the revolutionaries
want to force down our throats which is
that you know the whole past is wicked
and terrible and there's nothing red
there's nothing of value there at all
because once we do that we have it cut
ourselves off from the very sources of
the regeneration it's not that we return
to the past you can't return to the past
but it's like my image of trying to
build beautiful buildings without any
access to anything that's ever been been
been been been built before and
so what i what i what i really think is
a big problem
is and and this is in so-called
conservatism is i think you know deeply
fraught with this problem is that
we subordinate ourselves to the current
narratives to the idea that there is no
truth but only power you know to the
evisceration of our institutional life
rather than
take a contradistinctively positive
standpoint which you know
if i can say to you you know this is
what i think fundamentally is at work in
your work is is is is opening up a way
for individuals to more deeply
understand themselves and the world
around them um
in in
transformatively beautiful and difficult
ways
why do you stress why do you stress
architecture that that seems to have a
particular meaning for you
well for me it's it's it's
for a couple of reasons
but fundamentally it's is i choose
architecture as the example because i
think it's the most visible
um
uh it's the most visible represent
representation of what the ideas are and
i think the idea
you see in is
campuses like at the university of
toronto one side of it is cathedral
and the other side is brutalist factory
and that's it's like the university has
transformed itself from cathedral of
knowledge to brutalist factory of of of
classroom inculcation and that's that's
maybe not even so much reflected in the
architecture as led by the architecture
yes it's not that i think architecture
is alone enough i i choose it early on
for two reasons the first is that i
think it's the clearest way into what
the world view is i mean i'm a
philosopher we can talk about nihilism
and and the the negation of of higher
order goods and what those goods are but
you know that's not the language that
that most immediately rings with people
but if you show them a brutalist
building they get it that's what that
those where those ideas lead whereas
when you look at the great cathedrals or
even just a well-balanced simple town
hall i mean my my ancestors like my girl
was born in alberta as and grew up there
until i was uh uh eight years old
as you did in alberta and uh you know my
my ukrainian ancestors i mean they lived
in very very humble uh homes in uh i
mean
many of them lived in essentially dirt
shacks until they could build the next
generation the next year and they were
extremely simple homes and you can see
recreations of of these these elementary
forms of architecture
but they are beautiful i mean the idea
that somehow you know that you know
beauty is a rarefied thing that only
those who are wealthy have access to him
that's just completely wrong the most
one of the most beautiful buildings i
ever saw was a day laborers cottage from
the i think the 17th century in in the
netherlands and so the the point i'm i'm
making is that
is that
architecture matters both because it's a
symbol of what the closing down of the
horizon is and conversely a symbol of
what opening up of the horizon looks
like i mean you know if you if you live
in a place with a beautiful building
that
building becomes a means of
understanding yourself in some sense
that building is yours and it elevates
and opens you up you know the
proportions of the building uh the
symmetry that becomes a way of your
becoming proportioned or understanding
yourself as within those now i i don't
think by any means architecture is
sufficient i think in fact it's uh it's
even a subsidiary to higher order things
uh whether it's educational uh religious
uh civic political familial i mean the
turning on of the lights again the
opening up of the horizon needs to
happen in my view at every level in
every domain of our of our of our
culture and architecture is just one
example to help us understand both what
the closed or open horizon is and
uh
uh an instance of a domain that is
urgently in need given our epidemic of
ugliness urgently in need of um uh of
being
reopened again
what's your vision for ralston college
architecturally speaking
well we we are um
uh we're living in one ralston college
in savannah and so far as we we we have
and we'll have uh in-person programs
here our endeavor is to
uh to repurpose historic buildings in
the historic core in order to make the
this
sublimely beautiful uh historic downtown
the campus rather than to uh to build a
new now if we for example were to have
100 million dollars and build a new
campus in some beautiful
place
we would
really simply i think want for that to
be in coherent conversation with the
history of collegiate architecture um
but as i say fundamentally
we
we chose savannah actually because it is
a sublimely beautiful place and because
the
the natural and architectural beauty uh
we think uh is
a
powerful analog to the discovery of the
uh
intellectual riches of the classroom can
i ask you where the project is
at in its current state of development
uh cert certainly um
you know i would perhaps say just by
introduction that you know our analysis
and the need for founding new
institutions is directly related to the
things we've just been speaking about
the the cultural spiritual crisis the
upstream influence of the university
over everything else the fact that it is
the epicenter of
at very best unhelpful at worst uh
downright toxic forms of ideology that
spread through anything and everything
uh that isn't uh as catastrophically
beset with high costs low value and so
on and so forth but our analysis is
simply that um
the
uh
there is huge demand in young people for
alternatives people who are seeking
alternatives to the indoctrination and
activism and fraudulent low value of the
academy i mean i think your own work has
shown this uh about as clearly as
anything else historically ever has
that
it's a mistake to concede
the to be you know your new book you
write about the need for creative
dynamism in relation to our institutions
and it seems to me we're in in a in a
moment not only which that is urgently
necessary but also eminently possible if
we have only the courage to
uh to to do it um
so
what i would say is a few things the
first is that ralston college has has
really four fundamental commitments
first to seek the truth with courage
second
to apprehend beauty in all of its forms
third to the freedom of
speech and thought
that are the conditions of those
pursuits and finally to the
the friendship or even fellowship that
is the context for
all of these pursuits
and
you know what's become clear to us
jordan over the uh the years is of it's
it's been a long uh runway uh it's not
easy getting a college going uh you know
anyone who thinks that you need to go
off and fight in a war in order to
undertake something really hard of value
um
uh
can call me up and we'll have a talk
about other things other projects that
may be very very difficult to bring into
the world but
necessary and beautiful um what's become
clear to us in these uh these years of
development uh uh which we're sort of at
the end of as we we now are launching
our first programs and and first degree
is that ralston college has a double
vocation
both on the one hand to be a reinvention
of the academy
a place for in-person degrees uh uh a
new model for the university that can we
hope be pretty radically disruptive not
just because we're going to change
everything but we hope that it will lead
to many other people doing new and and
different and more beautiful and more
adequate and perhaps cheaper and faster
but above all just more important and
higher value
things in the space of higher education
so on the one hand to be a reinvention
of the uh the the academy a reinvention
and a revival of the academy uh but and
on that side we've
received our degree granting powers from
the state of georgia we expect to launch
our first degree this autumn in what in
what
this first degree will be a masters in
the humanities so it will be a pretty
intensive boot camp in thinking about
the big ideas tracing them and their
development through history
which we think is important both as a
revival of those forms of of life and
thought and culture but also because we
think they are the as it were the key to
opening up the uh depths of the self for
the students themselves um you know it's
not that every human if i can't play the
piano it's not that every um you talk
about resentment earlier you know it's
not that every
uh human being should have to play the
piano like martha archery or glenn gould
from your home your your current town of
toronto um uh
99.999 percent of human individuals
couldn't play the piano that way but
because glenn gould could and did
we can all hear the music and in some
level i think
what the
the the the high end of the academy is
about is about playing the music so we
can all
hear it
and uh and and so on the one hand it's
the reinvention of the academy um in in
in a degree form but on the other hand
the second side of this double vocation
is to be a kind of platform of
humanistic inquiry for anyone anywhere
who which is wishes to engage with the
the riches of the humanistic tradition
who wishes to seek the truth with
courage who who is who is who wishes to
ask the fundamental human questions that
that that every human being must face
about
truth and beauty and
forgiveness and love and suffering
it i put a reading list online of a
hundred books it's it's at jordanb
peterson.com under books for those who
might be interested in
people are buying those books like mad
and reading them and it does really seem
to me that
you know if you can open up access to
people to these great ideas and provide
them with a pathway that there's all
sorts of people who are more than
willing to tread down that pathway as
rapidly as possible
and so
you know i'm i'd be interested at as we
progress in this conversation at some
other point to know in more detail what
it is that you're planning but i would
like to ask right now i mean how do you
envision opening up the humanities to a
broader range of people
what are you going to do that's
different or what are you hoping to do
that's different
well well it you know this in one sense
it's it's
gosh you know
we have to confront the fact that the
universities have in many respects i'm
not a catastrophist i mean you know and
there are many wonderful people teaching
in many you know
institutions around the world it's not
like it's just all bad all the time
everywhere um but i think and i clarify
things because i don't want to be
perceived as a catastrophist while i say
that the universities have by and large
fundamentally forgotten if not betrayed
their fundamental value proposition well
what's happened to enrollment in the
humanities over the last 20 years my
understanding is that it's plummeted yes
of course it's dropping from everything
i
i i read uh but you know i think we can
look at this at a higher level of
resolution or a higher level of if we
zoom out a bit uh i think
we can say that when people the average
person anywhere in the world when they
are looking to make sense of their lives
whether it's suffering or loss or cancer
or or or or uh
joy or sorrow or or whatever that
the place they do not look for answers
to those questions is to the university
by and large and i think this tells us
we're living in a historic moment in
which the institutions that are meant to
have those questions at their heart
are no longer tending to them in any
uh
fundamentally visible way and so the the
do you think that's true of the church
as well
definitely i mean again with exceptions
here and there and so forth but i think
the
at least in my experience i can't speak
for other religious traditions
i think that
in many respects not again not as a
catastrophist but in many respects the
uh uh the
various denominations of the christian
religion have uh lost their way in a way
that is similar to the humanities having
lost their way and what i want to you
know just really insist upon is that you
know of course jordan you know that
there are certain kinds of
uh
intellectual activity or or
intellectual domains let's say you know
string theory or
um you know the the the highest and
hardest questions in philosophy that are
not fundamentally very easily accessible
uh to to anyone unless they have gone
through years of apprenticeship to be
able to encounter those questions
however the vast amount of humanistic
inquiry of art and music and literature
and architecture and
so on and so forth throughout virtually
every humanistic domain
are
not only accessible to
but are made for
the
enjoyment and illumination of uh human
beings
everywhere and anywhere
and
you know i i had a very moving
experience with someone who's quite
close to me and my um extended family
who
never really finished high school and
who is very uh intelligent
uh person uh i hasten to to add not that
intelligence should be any kind of
marker of value as a human being it is
not um but uh we were in london and uh
we were my wife and i were suggesting we
should go to shakespeare's globe and uh
spend some you know go watch a
shakespearean play
and this person in my extended family
was who's very very dear to me was quite
insecure about about going and she
really sort of said you know
no you know i won't understand anything
you know i'll go off and you know walk
around and you all go and enjoy
shakespeare's you know her view was
shakespeare's not for me
but we insisted and she came along and
it was a play i had never had seen
before and here i had my you know phd
and whatever
and by the intermission
i am not exaggerating to say she knew
far more about what was happening in the
play than i did
and
what i want to insist jordan is that you
know the great
high water marks of the humanities
whether it's
bach or matisse or the gothic cathedrals
uh or or or homer or just go on and down
through the list of all of it they are
made for everyone and
the so the the question is you know how
do you open them up well i mean damn it
we're going to do everything we can to
open them up however we can i mean
you're one of our great examples of how
you open things up i mean you you you
you think about them you try and share
them in a medium that seems right for a
certain audience and you know you can't
you can't do everything to everyone all
the time i mean there are some things
that you can do in the internet and some
things you can't do in the internet some
things you can do in person in a weekend
some things take a whole year um but the
point is is that by and large the
internet gives us the opportunity and
modern travel gives us the opportunity
of gathering people either virtually or
in person
totally extra territorially to the to
the university why should the university
have to be the place that these things
are these things are better encountered
i mean most of your work though i know
you were formed and shaped in the
university the vast amount of your work
that has reached large audiences has not
taken place in the university and so i
think that or that's where the
university has moved yes
truly conceived the university is um
as the community of those who
pursue the truth yes it's like israel is
those who struggle with god and the
university is those who struggle with
the truth
yes exactly so you know i
would say that we think that there is
enormous opportunity we have a
partnership now with a global online
learning platform called future learn
which grew out of the open university in
the united kingdom with i think it's 15
million users in 200 countries our first
courses will go up on futurelearn open
access available to anyone anywhere with
an internet connection there's no credit
there's no uh you're not getting a a
a degree we're just trying to share
these things as widely as we can the
first course will be tony daniels aka
theodore dalrymple who's i know some of
whose books are on your your uh uh
reading list on uh uh johnson's racilis
uh uh which is gonna be a wonderful
course andrew doyle is doing a course on
uh shakespeare's titus andronicus and so
on and so forth we'd love to have have
uh uh have you joined this initiative at
some point if you're able um and
interested
the point is is that
we
we live in actually very exciting times
from the standpoint of the sharing of
information uh freely at low cost uh uh
through the internet and that's not that
you know which which should be internet
ideologues as if everything meaningful
in life can be done in the internet it
cannot be but we should at the same time
as you have very beautifully and
courageously shown embrace the
possibilities that it does in fact offer
us and you know
our
deepest hope is that we can if i can use
a scriptural metaphor you know break the
alabaster box and take the greatest most
beautiful minds we can find and to have
them share the things that they know and
understand
for
anyone who is seeking
to ask those questions to encounter
those truths to look at those beautiful
things and to understand um
understand themselves more truly and
love others more fully i mean it's in a
way a very simple endeavor but we i
think have to insist that that we ought
not to be captive to the closed horizon
that would tell us you know
it's too late it's not possible
the very hunger
the deafening hunger around us is a sign
that it
that
at a minimum we can try to give what we
can to those who seek it
that's a really good place to stop
thanks very much for talking with me
today
stephen thank you best of luck with your
initiative and thank you very much for
the conversation
thank you jordan for having me
[Music]
foreign